hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and welcome to my front
yard and we're gonna take these autumn
olive berries and we're gonna turn them
into fruit leather
[Music]
welcome to another episode of outdoor
boys and today me and Nathan we're out
picking autumn olives we're on the East
Coast it's the end of September
and the autumn olives are ripe and ready
to be picked autumn olives are an
invasive species of Bush it makes this
wonderful little red berry
it's very tart kind of like a cranberry
but it's great in jams and we're gonna
try to make fruit leather with it or
fruit roll-ups so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna show you how to identify them
how to pick up process them the whole
shebang and this is something we like to
do every year it's just been a really
fun tradition isn't that right neat so
these right here are autumn olive bushes
they usually don't get more than ten
twelve feet tall and they've got these
long drooping smooth leaves right here
but the most distinct characteristics is
the berries grow along the stems and if
you look close the berries are red with
these yellow spots on them and as you
can see here they get really thick
they're just tons of them very
distinctive and inside the berry there's
a single pit so the best way to pick
them is just get a big basket and put
them under the book the branches and
just go down and just take your fingers
and rub the berries off when they're
ripe they should just fall off really
easy just working them between your
fingers like that don't worry if you get
leaves and stems and stuff in there
you'll sort it out later well there you
go about 15 seconds of picking and look
at all the berries we already have good
job Nate
look at all these berries just four or
five minutes of picking yeah we're gonna
get a lot of berries today so here you
can see on the underside you can see
more of the berries you can get
underneath the the boughs yeah oh
there's so much
look at this it's just you're not
picking berries you're picking clusters
of berries so this is all the berries
from just one bush so you can see there
that's a pretty good pile of fruit just
from one autumn olive bush maybe 40
minutes of picking last year this bush
was crazy full of berries so we got
loads of berries off it and this bush
over here didn't have very many now this
year that bush is loaded and this one
has hardly any and they're really late
ripening this year so if you want to
find autumn olive bushes look in places
that have full sunlight usually the edge
of meadows on riverbeds but most
importantly on bike trails and roads
along the edges with this full sunlight
so that's where we're going right here
and we've got this big highway here with
the bike path along it and we're gonna
go look for autumn olives along the bike
path
over here there's just tons of
blackberry bushes you tend to find
autumn olives the same place as you find
blackberries but the blackberries are
more of the middle of the summer autumn
olives our end of September beginning of
October you can spot the autumn olive
bushes from quite a ways away they've
got this bluish green hue to the leaves
see right there
this autumn olive has kind of wrinkly
leaves but not many berries not many
berries
there we go here's another good one
oh yeah here we go
yeah look how thick they are up in here
look at this this is crazy about the
berries got about half a five-gallon
bucket there let's go get another bush
[Applause]
another bush oh yeah this one's this
one's got some berries on it not a lot
of berries on this bush but they're
really dark red and plump you'll see
that there's a lot of variation in the
coloration of the berries
Nathan's decided he's gonna pick some
flowers for mommy which i think is
really nice there you go here's another
one look how pale the berries that are
on this one you can see a real
difference in the coloration of the
berries
here's another autumn olive tree see out
there a lot of variation in the leaves
and the berries but you see there's just
lots of them
all down here
[Applause]
[Music]
I think that's it Nate I don't think
we'd get any more in there wow this is
really heavy well there we go have a
heaping five-gallon bucket full of
autumn olives took us three hours so
about a gallon and a half per hour all
right let's go home so you can see here
we have a big bucket of autumn olives
but there's a lot of sticks and twigs
and leaves and there's a few nasty
berries and bugs in here so what we're
gonna do is sort that all out is we're
going to take that and put it in here
with a bunch of fresh clean water and
all the bad stuff is gonna float to the
top and the good berries will slowly
sink to the bottom we're just gonna
scoop that stuff out a lot of the rotten
berries will float to the surface too so
see right there just like a little Weir
agitate the berries a little bit to try
to free up some of the stems and leaves
to float to the surface so I've been
letting the water run for a little while
let's see how it's done well it's a lot
clearer there's still a little bit here
and there floating in the water but
we'll get that out with the next step
it's really clean there's just a few
bits here and there it's a couple old
shriveled ones we're gonna get out it's
a couple really green ones we're gonna
pull out 34 pounds of autumn olives so I
want to do is we want to separate the
flash and the juice from the pit and to
do that we're gonna use a food mill
which is this little propeller thing of
a jiggy that squishes food over a sip
and you can buy different sized sips for
a food mill right here this is a 1/8
inch sieve and it's the perfect size
because it's just barely a small enough
to keep the pits from going through but
you can see I'm
doing this with raw autumn olives
nothing's coming out
it's just squishing them no flesh will
come through here unless you cook them
first
so we're gonna boil the autumn olive
just to get them nice and liquidy and
soft so that they'll squish through the
sieve but the pits will stay behind
once you pick autumn olives they go bad
pretty quickly if you leave them in the
bucket on a normal fall day at 70
degrees they'll go bad in about a day
and a half two days I'm gonna put that
on a medium heat and we're gonna let
that start to cook all right so I've had
this boiling for about two hours and you
can see the pits have really separated
from the Jews and its really turned into
kind of a soupy mix after a few minutes
of running this through the food mill
you've got mostly pits and stems and a
little bit of skins left inside the food
mill and underneath this you've got kind
of a puree check it out guys this is the
puree I pushed through the food mill and
you can see it's about the consistency
of tomato soup but we want it thicker I
don't want it to run all over the cookie
sheet when I pour it onto the wax paper
to make the fruit leather if I do it'll
make the fruit leather very thin and I'd
like it a little bit harder so we're
gonna reduce it by just letting it
simmer and letting all this steam drive
the moisture out of it and get it
thicker and thicker I'm gonna add a
little bit of sugar and a little bit of
honey you can do either one or as much
or as little as you want
I know this looks like a lot of sugar
and honey but this is 34 pounds of fruit
so it's getting very diluted breathing
all right so I got some parchment paper
here I'm gonna lay it down I'm gonna put
it in the oven at the lowest setting
possible which is a hundred and seventy
degrees on this oven you can use cookie
sheets cake pans whatever you want but
fill the oven up how much time it takes
to dry the fruit leather is a little bit
of a question mark how thick you make it
how much moisture is in the jelly all of
these things vary from batch to batch so
just kind of eyeball it put it in for
3-4 hours and start checking on it every
couple hours and pull out when it's
ready now another way of making it is to
use a food dehydrator and you see I've
got one set up right here and you've got
this little fruit leather trade that
usually comes with them so instead of
using the wax paper you put it on the
tray this one's set to 130 degrees and I
have it running for 10 hours and it is
almost done
I think the way you'll find is that my
fruit leather is quite thick I'm making
a harness leather rather than suede so
it takes a little bit longer to dry it
when you put a really thick layer of it
let's check out the fruit leather
feels pretty good
all right there we go some lovely pieces
of autumn olive fruit leather from the
dehydrator the one in the glass is on
the bottom and it was in there way too
long this in the strips I use a pizza
cutter to do this nice piece of fruit
leather do you like it well we got to
tell you that fruit leather comes out
really really well but just make sure
you don't burn it so check the corners
and little bits around and make sure
it's not getting too crispy all right
I'm gonna try something I've never done
before we're gonna try to make an autumn
all of it and strawberry pie here I've
never made a pie before so what the Hey
got some store-bought crusts I once saw
a TV show where they put some
strawberries in a pie crust and covered
them with a little bit of sugar all
right so then we just take this jelly
leftover jelly from that and that is
like blue-ribbon County Fair right there
that's
there yeah the package said to let it
cook for 10 minutes so it's been about
20 let's see and as I look to bad flaky
crust it's like cutting into a baby
rabbit look at that you know that is
extraordinarily juicy
I should mean I should have put some
pectin or something and so Chris what do
you think I should have done to make it
thick out of some cornstarch did you
just look that up on your phone I did
double check so so apparently if I had
added some cornstarch maybe it would
have been thicker but if you know how to
make pie fillings you leave a comment
and let me know I think it's really
brings out the flavor of the week old
Wendy's Frosty's no well I hope you
enjoyed this video and learn to view
things about eating stuff I find in my
yard if you want to see more great
videos from the outdoor boys YouTube
channel don't forget to click Subscribe
we put out new videos every Saturday
morning thanks for watching